[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
round three of the norm Congress here in
st. Louis
in the Grand Master section stavroula
Seoul Aikido could not force a
repetition with her Queen
against John Bartholomew Bartholomew won
with two powerful rooks
this allowed Grandmaster Mark Parag WA
to claim the undisputed lead after he
beautifully checkmated Grandmaster Pablo
Vorontsov in the middle of the board
meanwhile in the International Master
section it was a great day for the black
pieces for decisive games all in blacks
favor including International Master
Louise Torres who's charging past pawn
could not be stopped
forcing Josh colas to resign Torres now
leads the field by half a point coverage
of round four begins now players all
over the world have struggled to earn
the Grandmaster title which players will
earn a norm which players will go home
with the prize welcome to the 2018 st.
Louis norm Congress
hello chess fans and welcome back to st.
Louis for the 2018 the st. Louis norm
Congress Ben Simon along with
Grandmaster Josh Friedel here in the
studio in the midst of round four of the
Grand Master and international master
normal events Josh we already have a
couple of results in but before we get
to those games let's take a look at the
fields of players in this event the
Grand Master norm field the top field
right here we have the ten players in
this event and it's a pretty strong
field I would definitely say so with
four grandmasters four international
masters two very strong women's
grandmasters pretty nice fields and I
would say definitely could still be
anyone's couldn't still be anyone's win
so far
Stocki Brewer has two points and GM
marker Agua has two and a half out of
three so he's leading but could still be
anyone's tournament for sure and we have
a second field here let's take a look at
the International master norm roster
also ten players in this field and these
players there they're played for
international master norm international
master norms so you have the three
gatekeepers near the top and then the
rest of the contenders below exactly and
those Iams are going to try to make sure
that they are the ones who stay the only
ions in that section but it won't be
easy all the ways the people trying to
play for norms are pretty hungry and
let's take a look at the tournament
format here this is pretty simple to
understand
we have 210 player round robins and all
the players will start with a base time
of 90 minutes with a 30 second increment
from move number one and so these games
will probably go three to four hours you
know last night the games the last game
might end at like 9:30 p.m. or something
so every day 11 a.m. and 5 p.m. that's
when we're gonna have the games but
let's take
the full schedule here because this is
something that you should definitely
write down it join us at us chest champs
calm for the full event here we are in
round four on Saturday 11:00 a.m. at 5
p.m. the round is in progress round 4 is
tomorrow we'll have the sixth and
seventh round at 11:00 a.m. and then
5:00 p.m. and then the penultimate round
has its own day along with the final
round on February 12th and Tuesday
February 13th respectively both of those
days will be at 11 a.m. so those are all
central time of course here in st. Louis
so wake up and get some coffee maybe you
be at work and catch the finale of this
event but last night we had round 3 we
were not live on the air let's take a
look at what exactly happened the full
results from the grand master dorm
section yeah a few drawers definitely
these drawers could have gone either way
they weren't just you know basic drawers
but so lucky though who was to know had
a setback she lost as white to John
Bartholomew I think she played a slight
mistake in the opening tried to sack too
much material ended up just not having
enough Queen verse 2 rooks in the night
couldn't save the game and John
Bartholomew picked up his first win so
that was nice for him and Marat saw of
quite honestly seemed to lose his mind
against Mark Parag WA and just got
confused destroyed it was it was quite
something to watch and we hope that
you're keeping up with the games on us
chess champs calm remember along with
this live stream you're watching check
out the live games as they happen you'll
even have to wait for us to talk about
them it's a really great experience the
best way to watch chess on this planet
to be quite frank let's take a look at
last night at the results from the
International Master norm section hold
draw which you know as opposed to the
first round where all the sides the
results although I should point out that
this result this draw between Turgenev
Matt Cinco at the very end
turgid actually had a win in the king
upon end game
but couldn't quite find the right path
so that's how they drew all the other
games quite quite interesting battles
and you can see right there who ended up
on top so now Torres is leading the
event by meeting call us and they both
had one and a half so now Torres has two
and a half he's in comfortable lead at
the moment yeah it let's let's put these
results into a readable form first of
all the Grandmaster norm standings after
round three from top to bottom and with
a clear lead now from mark Parag WA so
lakitu though we might actually be
talking to her today and we're gonna
reference that a little bit later on but
mark is uh isn't clearly the Grandmaster
on top of the event and now for the
International master norm standings as
well let's take a look at those Josh any
comments I mean it looks like Taurus is
in the lead for the moment he has a very
interesting game going now which again
my opinion could really go either way
he's playing tension at the moment but
yeah and huge huge tie for second with
two and really anything can happen there
and even the players towards the bottom
wing Chi usual Brandon Jacobson they're
not doing so well right now but again
you can come back there's still plenty
of time to come back so don't write
anyone off just yet and there's a lot
more to play for even if the norms
eventually become out of reach for the
players
we've got prizes here so let's take a
look at the prize fund and the breakdown
for the Grandmaster norm field up to
$2,000 for first place pretty good even
though like we said a lot of these
players they're not thinking about the
money they use that I mean sometimes you
have to pay to play in these kinds of
events that's absolutely true and some
of these players are used to playing
events for even for much bigger money
however to play for norms with this kind
of prize fund is a pretty nice deal and
as you can see the last players all get
about the same prize and the reason for
that is it basically covers your
expenses so that these players can come
here not lose too much money and get a
shopfront
at plan for norms in the International
Master norms section has its own fund
it's a little bit less because it is our
B section so to speak but still pretty
good and you get your
expenses covered at the very least we do
it right here in st. Louis that's for
sure
most certainly now today the round is in
progress let's take a look at the
pairings for the Grand Master norm
section round number four what stands
out to you here what stands out to you
Josh well as mentioned adi patel already
beat daniel Gurevich so that result is
in that leaves Gurevich with half a
point out of four pretty rough result
for him still time to come back but it's
difficult in an event like this because
every opponent is strong just because
you lose doesn't mean you get a weaker
opponent so he can come back for sure
but it's gonna be tough
addy patel moves to +1 puts himself in
contention for norms otherwise just lots
of interesting games I think Bartholomew
and paraguas solid game heading towards
a draw so perago will probably maintain
a tie for the lead
however so the kid who looked last I
checked like she was on the - the good
against Danish Boros so she could end up
tied for first after this round and we
got a hold that game in high regard as
one of our games to watch definitely a
key matchup of the day and actually she
did win oh it's oh I just saw yep okay
we're definitely gonna have to talk to
her let's hope that was our game of the
day now as far as the parents for the
International master norm section for
round four this is what's happening
right now yep and I'd say so Stearman
already lost to Josh coalesce to josh
coalesced a +1 Stearman I believe gets
knocked down to 50% otherwise we got the
game still going Luis Torres again
stencil target that's one of the games I
have my eye on otherwise might say ko is
trying to put his stamp on the field
being the most highest rated I think
that he is a pretty good position
against zero out of three random
Jacobson can you imagine having zero to
three and having to play the top seed at
welcome to round robin chest
absolutely yeah there's some definitely
some games to watch in the international
master norm section
okay well Josh let's take a look around
the horn but we'll wait for our
interview what games would you like to
look at first well I want to first show
the very quick game this actually game
finished in about an hour I believe
between Adi Patel and Daniel
and I wanted to focus on this moment
because I thought this was a moment
where things kind of went awry Gurevich
was black playing Carroll comedies lots
of experience in in this position I
thought if it were me I probably would
have played Bishop e7 I trade off the
bishops
get canceled I might allow Knight takes
e4 96 in a cage and we'll worry but
honestly I felt like black was a little
bit worse but not doing so bad I think
he got a little too ambitious tried to
play Queen b8 and now he had massive
development problems Bishop takes c4
notice how this Bishop has trouble
getting out now because if you play
Bishop e7 I can take this guy taking
here will be a mistake cuz I take back
and hit this bishop you have to take
back I take here your King ends up in
the center just complete disaster
and not being able to develop needless
to say Bensimon is not good that's the
first things I learned so one of the
first things you got to learn develop
your pieces and basically black just
never got developed he took this Knight
but the Queen got out now Bishop takes
six is in the air with Queen h5 Trek as
a potentially nasty shot so he could got
rid of that Bishop but now Knights
coming into d6
this bishops still can't get out you
don't want to play g5 and weak to your
king it's just an unpleasant situation
and the game ended very abruptly rook
takes d4 really nice shot it looked like
he was kind of getting out but rook
takes d4 the ideas of Bishop takes
Knight d6 check hitting this pawn so you
must sack the Queen that's obviously no
good plays Queen c7 simply doubles rooks
same problem if you take the rook and
here the game ended quite abruptly he
played Knight takes e5 thinking that he
could maybe get himself castled if
Knight takes e5 maybe Bishop takes d4 he
holds on
but now about rage is shot Queen takes
b7 the idea is that of course if you
take the Queen you get mated in rather
brutal fashion and there's absolutely
nothing to do basically you have to hang
your queen hang your rook get mated none
of those choices were Pleasant he
resigned here quite a first game in the
tournament and really just not not so
good for good a abit shoe is a much
stronger player than this but again when
you're struggling in such a strong field
it's just hard to hard to recover but
let's hope he kind of gets
everything together after this game but
very nice for addy Patel who moves the
+1 all right
indeed two and a half now out of four
for a Deepa toe
yep I should show Josh colas one as
black against Josiah Steerman and in
this game I thought that the key moment
was around here where colas is
definitely better colas is on top
technically he's down upon it for the
time being but what White's pieces are
really bad blacks pieces are really nice
this D pawn is hanging so but here white
kind of panicked a little bit I thought
that he should probably play rookie to
hit this pawn there's a nice little
trick that if rook takes d4 you can
actually play rook takes c6 and the idea
is that if rook takes c6 there's Knight
g5 check winning the rook back of course
black doesn't have to take this pawn
black could play a move like King e7 and
life kind of goes on I prefer black but
honestly it's not that clear white
panicked and took on d5 and quite
honestly it wasn't enough through the
exchange if black took with the C pawn
white as a connected passer on c5 that's
pretty rough but after he takes d5 white
really just doesn't have enough like
took this F pawn but after Keeney 7 you
have two pawns for the exchange but
quite honestly these pawns are not good
this Knight is passive and it was just a
matter of time till he converted they
traded the rooks g3 rook takes d4
snacking on another pawn these two pawns
are just not good enough and eventually
white white just didn't get enough
Brooke h4 this night is bad these pawns
are getting collected it's gonna be
pretty bad news so next we actually are
going to have an interview with stuff
Rula soloqueue and she won a very nice
game against Danish Burroughs so here
she is welcome okay so why don't you
take us through your game yes
so just tell me when to stop any point
Kings idiot okay it's Kings India
everybody it wasn't like you first time
in your life Saudi five
yeah night at five is a pretty
interesting move yeah I have checked
this position before but it we really
remember in such detail I would say this
is a dangerous position not to remember
my thanks to do fine yeah I think net h4
s other move but 95 is met it seems
other move and then they pitch their
night here and I don't know to me these
positions just look like a mess but yeah
it's great so f6 so hit some playing
experience I believe it's game to this
line yeah so explain the purpose in sin
Chi of G for because it might look a
little weird to something yes maybe it's
not sorry but I think anyone up in the D
Phi yeah yeah yes so it makes sense I
think Bishop e3 is the other move and
just kind of finish development that
might be what I do but g4 I think it's a
very aggressive try which is interesting
when it's a thing but it worked out well
for you negative six so thanks I'll be
fine and Bishop III night before yeah I
wasn't sure about night before actually
but I thought that black might try c6 I
don't know if you consider this one CC
trying to open it because then your King
might feel a little uncomfortable this
is my my thought at least I have not a
hundred percent sure of it but so it
looked like maybe a better try for him I
wasn't sure really good yeah rook g1
King yeah maybe maybe he's okay uh
before but yeah you played a really
excellent move coming up so rooks you
are clearly stakes maybe it's not so
good yeah because of thing to do which
is surprisingly strong yeah so this is
the thing like you know people see a
mullah
do when they're thinking if she lost
their mind but it's a really good move
like why is it such a good news actually
I hope like this I think this very exact
this very exact position in the bleach
games so that's really all my mind could
ever go through this move if I haven't
blaming but it's amazing because without
this move I think blacks just doing
great but after King D to save save and
then the rook comes to g1 this Queens
misplace this Knights misplaced it's
like a nightmare all of a sudden so
black played aged six so you won this
bishop oh maybe before Queens a six
maybe photos right there
no we six o not could you six yeah
before so trying to play Knight d3 on
you again whatever any move but let's
let's check it out so it takes takes I
liked your position here a lot Queen f5
this all looked pretty good a 3e seven I
lights
I remember here I thought instead of c5
Bishop g4 was made me very strong yeah
basically I'm always happy if you take
because you open up everything and if
you don't take where does your Queen go
cuz if you go to g6 I play with Geelong
so I didn't see a good move for black
here I saw me some Department yeah well
what you did worked out really well it's
hard to criticize but after c5 I thought
he'd play King h8 it was bad that was
your plan here what if I been here it
wasn't your just playing it by ear
figure I'll figure it out later yeah I
mean you still have Bishop g4 but at
least I can move back and it's not so
bad well yeah you know it's maybe they
can this yeah I thought you would take
just a closing smile I was a nervous
yeah
but okay it's just sing line um but yeah
after d5 I think the yeah yeah
takes I thought even here Bishop you for
is completely crushing but your move of
courses this was a really nice resource
though because at first it looks tricky
but fortunately Kingu why did you see
this in advance or was it just all right
well pretend you five minutes
so King you wine-soaked we take say five
Bishop c4 yes to show people here and
that would be unpleasant
so Knight takes d5 before M so after
here I think you can play look do you
want or Bishop Ephraim yeah yeah and you
wouldn't back this night this pawn is
actually very convenient because it
covers the square yeah
and after this I think it was just
losing right you take yeah take this
along you have the two bishops your King
safe everything and here I didn't see
the very end of the game was there any
other moment you thought was important
oh man this guy's trapped yeah
everything is a temple yeah you didn't
have to take this pawn one we're not
actually fine so that he won't have any
Luke 800 and then you pin and Brooke f6
the other real cap is to hang this score
is covered by the bishop when you
dominate the board as much itself so
really nice game so you moved to three
out of four you had a tough loss last
night it seemed like a waiting game
but you recovered really nicely so you
know how are you you know are you
feeling confident or you feel like you
can playing really well I definitely
expect to come early but it looks like
things are going your way
um why you tell us a little about
yourself cuz most of us you know I
didn't know you before this event
probably lots of other people so you're
from wearing Amala I've been declawed
actually really nice I went to a
tournament though come on open yeah it's
a pretty strong it's a little bit very
nice place it's not a bad place to live
so tell us more yeah actually because
that is a very and we have very good
chess club
yeah I think our people from the Chess
Club of very first time so was it
excited than though so anxious yeah yeah
makes perfect sense
okay nice yeah and I guess the last
thing I'd like to know is I actually
asked a Greek friend how to pronounce
your name it's like so lucky to take
heed Lou like you do all right no Jack
yeah interesting
okay well call you okay anyways all
right um well thanks for thanks for
showing your game would've luck in the
rest
yeah
yeah some problems
you
to another game ah one of the games of
the day that I wanted to go over from
the I am section was Torres against that
Salter food and the this game was a
really really fascinating game I thought
so the opening it started out there was
a key moment in the opening I wanted to
cover it was a semi Slav which triggered
played in round 2 as well and they
reached this position now this was I
thought a really interesting moment
because it looks like White's played
very standard put the knight on c4 and
White's idea is to play Bishop a3 sink a
9 to d6 I think of what accomplishes
that where does a good position but
again and I haven't checked everything
with engines for 20 hours but to me it
looked like this move b5 was actually
rather annoying the idea being if you
take Black has a nice structure you
don't have Bishop a3 anymore
you're not as solid and if the knight
has to move back now there's no 96
anymore I thought that even after a move
like a5 would be 4 thoughts it's
probably pretty pretty comfortable for
black however in the game he played
Knight of fate and now after Bishop a3
something night and I kind of like
White's position but then again it was
still very complicated they move forward
here I thought that actually f3 was a
very clever move threatening to take on
e4 asking the Queen where it's going but
he actually played f4 which I liked a
little bit less because it seemed to
pass the move to black at least maybe
Knight h4 Queen g6 is an idea I wasn't
sure about f4 is f3 but still quite an
interesting battle so let's move forward
night d1 trying to play Knight f2 i'd
imagine trying to reposition this knight
h5 again i thought that black might try
in knight h4 with the idea of queen g6
which to me at least looks pretty
annoying because then there's g2 squares
under some threat all of this after h5
knight be 295 d5 square is definitely
nice for the night but honestly i just
hate that pawn on d6 I feel like blacks
always the one who has to
something and that if white ever gets to
a position where his pieces get too
strong squares that pawn is just gonna
be so annoying and any endgame any
position where you take on d6 that's
gonna be a nasty poem so f6 I'm always
tempted to sack that any five anyway you
know just takes F takes have everything
open but of course unlike myself Lewis
is not necessarily a lunatic
he plays Queens e1 it's hitting the h5
pawn h3 so now Bishop g4 is a threat
council moves his knight back to f8
which makes sense guarding the g7 Bishop
Bishop g4 Queen g6 takes notice how he
declined actually to play Bishop h5
which seems to win the exchange
I guess this maybe he just didn't want
the exchange or it could be he was
worried about Queen g3 and Bishop h3
followed by taking this Bishop not
exactly sure but I'm guessing that's
what he was worried about so he took and
play Queen e1 H four pawns under some
threat Queen h5 rook f2 my guess is he's
gonna try to double on the C file g5 g 5
looks a little reckless to my eyes but
at the same time I kind of understand
like if he just sits White's gonna gang
up on the C pawn and if he crashes
through there it's gonna be really tough
but g5 looks almost suicidal to me it
kind of reminds me of what council did
in round 2 where he kind of just pushed
everything and things got a little crazy
but he did this king h1 King H aids
rookie 2 which to me looks a little bit
funny but I'm guessing he wants to move
that C night and play 92 to f1 maybe
rook c8 and
it huh raucous yet
there we are wasn't updating 92 a5 Queen
f2 rook f1 so notice how because black
opened up the King side white changed
his plans and it's like alright if
you're gonna open up the Kings side
that's what I'm gonna play so that seems
to be the current position and I don't
know who would you rather be then it's a
tough call really I perhaps turgut no no
it looks a little unsettling for both
sides yeah it's one of those things
where this net on d5 looks really nice
everything you know but this pawn on d6
is just always a nightmare and I don't
know I'd be worried about all these
pawns kind of dropping at some point the
black King looks a little unsafe to me
but you know what I think as a practical
try what he did was interesting because
at least forced Louise to alter his
plans otherwise he could have just
crashed through on the taking the C pawn
and you know he might just have been a
one-sided game but because he did this
at atleast forced white to kind of adapt
I don't know if white had to be so
drastic with trying to defend on the
Kings side but honestly I'd say that
it's one of those positions where it
could just collapse for black but if
things hold together
you never know that knight on d5 is a
nice piece he has a good-looking Queen
side that's marching forward interesting
game and I think that this is definitely
one to keep an eye on Justin I'm sorry
Josh I had jester on my mind because I
don't know if you had seen but Justin
Wang and geojo elsewhere in this field
have draw Justin got a draw because he
looked like he was in trouble let's
check this out looks like it was a
perpetual yeah so they had this position
right I thought that Justin was honestly
just downed two pawns his life did not
look so Pleasant and I guess he thought
the same because he decided you know
what guys let's make things interesting
shall we saxon bishop on h6 and you know
what sometimes these moves are not
objectively best but they're practical
because your opponent then has to change
their mindset they have to change to
defense they have to change from
technique to making sure they defend now
if they do defend and end up up a piece
might be a poor decision but sometimes
even if it's objectively not the best
it's a good practical decision
and obviously it was just because it
worked out easy to say in hindsight I
suppose so he takes and plays 93 this is
kind of clever trying to play Knight f5
and again I have a feeling this is just
not sound but at the same time what
these Knights out of play
the rooks not really contributing a lot
of pieces floating near blacks King I
would be a little worried also so she
played tonight Queen f6 this walks into
Knight G for Queen g6 and now Justin
changed his mind said he's like alright
I'm not gonna try to keep the Queen's on
in an attack I'm actually just gonna
trade them and play rook d7 and now the
problem is that Knight f6 check and
Knight takes h6 check are both
threatened and with these Knights coming
in that's pretty scary so she decides
probably wisely to play Bishop f6 and
say you know what Justin you can have
your draw and after Knight f6 Knight h7
Knight f6 and they draw this way I'm
guessing that trying to take this rook
on the 8th is not a good idea because
now you go back and your best try is
maybe to go back but then this would be
to you no longer have a drug this f6
Square is covered so they and agreed to
a draw so I'd say really nice
resourceful play by Justin Lang any
other results since we last and yet
let's read games left in both sections
yeah so let's check out actually this is
quite something I thought that Mark
Parag WA had more or less than equal
ending games John Bartholomew but it
seems to me judging from this position
that bart has outplayed him a little bit
so let's check out this position so they
got to this end game which honestly I
thought maybe slightly prefer to be
white but it's so difficult to ever get
an e4 because the d4 pawn so weak that I
thought that objectively probably close
to equal but again I think that John is
a really solid player but he also likes
to press like a lot of those players do
and I feel like this is his type of
position whereas Parag WA likes active
play he likes to be able to do things
and honestly I don't feel like this is
as comfortable a position 4
as it is for John so rook b5 was played
and again it's just a little bit
uncomfortable King c7 he marches his
King to b7 and again it's hard to say
where the king actually wants to be
whether this is a good square or not
so King d3 oh yeah so here it looked
like I don't know why it's moving the
pieces for me sorry about this guy's no
but I turned it off anyway yeah as you
can see this moment was before the
computer hijacked my moves I wish I
could do that during a regular game I'd
probably play better but in this
position it seemed like things were more
or less under control but does e5 move I
do not like at all and I'm guessing he
missed something tactical cuz there's no
way he would allow takes and this
protected past pawn on d5 this looks
like a nightmare to me yes you're not
threatening the night but this pawn is a
permanent strength and black is now
really under the gun night b8 a5 this
pawn is trying to make this pawn into a
weakness Bishop goes to c5 but quite
honestly I think that Jon's gonna really
push for a win here and it looks very
unpleasant yeah John looks like he's in
great position he don't make his type of
position trying to press trying to you
know use his advantage he has a lot of
time again this advantage is going
nowhere this this is a permanent
advantage with the pawn on d5 as you can
see they they got to this position with
you know he took on b6 and now we might
be considering Bishop a5 move sometimes
probably 97 it's no big deal he might
try Bishop before trading off that
Bishop trying to move the knight in
somewhere or he might just try to play
slower and honestly it's gonna be a
tough defense
you know Parag was a resourceful player
I'm sure he'll find some ideas but quite
honestly it looks very unpleasant to me
so he might lose his lead and stuck
mostly Sorolla and I feel bad every time
I say her name now because I'm sure I'm
getting it completely wrong but she tell
you that she did but I can't do it
yeah there are limitations American
curse what am I gonna do I give her
credit because there's so many foreign
players I ask how do you say your name
and they say just say it how you want to
cuz they did like don't want to
embarrass me or something yeah no really
just I want to try my best but with her
is really a we can't even hope it's
pretty difficult in any case though
difficult name or not her chest has been
pretty strong and I'd say that it looks
like she might be leading but we
shouldn't count our chickens too early
because obviously John still has some
technical work to do I like what he did
he played a four here
the idea being of course if you take and
I take I now have two connected passers
I don't have to tell you how dangerous
those are and quite honestly it already
looks close to lost maybe he has some
resources here I'm sure if there are
resources Marc will find them but quite
honestly I would hate to be black here
do you think I mean is there any chance
John could mess up I mean they're
getting down into time trouble here I
there's a 30 second deck of it though
well let me put it this way there are
always chances of messing up any player
you know you never have to ask that
question it's always possible however I
would say that objectively he probably
is winning or close to winning and I
think this is his type of position I
don't see him messing it up but you
never know and again Marc's very
resourceful if there's a trick he'll
find it you still have to be careful but
objectively I just hate everything about
his position right now and again it all
started from allowing this passer on d5
which should have been almost impossible
to get so sometimes one little mistake
in an equal endgame is all it takes
so why don't we move around yeah they
did do this by the way they took here
Bishop takes yeah I think these palms
are just running I don't see it there
are tricks everywhere true for example
of rook e8 there's rook takes b6 check
whoopsies because the bishop takes you
take here way to another you win the
rook back and win another pawn nice yeah
it's first tactic to get it anyway but
yeah he'll probably play rook d7 or
something like this but quite honestly
it just looks almost hopeless notice our
rook d7 also cuts off his own Knight so
I don't expect resignation anytime soon
but it looks
dream Li extremely unpleasant and maybe
even here there's a tactic maybe you can
take this pawn go here rook has to come
here ah but okay after Oh No Bishop c5
hitting this rook the rook has to move
somewhere right because you can't defend
it because everything hangs you five
maybe ninety seven you you hang on
somehow
but even this I'd imagine is probably
losing because this pawn is just way too
far you play here rook comes over I
don't know if I'll actually go for this
this is quite quite far afield he
actually played rook f8 though I don't
think Mark is gonna miss too many
tactics but at the same time this looks
pretty bad so I'd say that good chance
for a white win here let's move on I
thought that Tata of a baraja Mian had a
really interesting game on our hands
against pavlova rensef I can show you I
mean this position is already very
interesting just to show you how the
opening developed it was actually quite
interesting it was a you know it starts
out as close gyoko piano just you know
normal line thought those played it many
times and then bronson plays aged six
which is kind of a trend now actually
they're trying to be more ambitious
rather than putting the bishop out here
they're trying to play h6 d6 and play g6
Bishop d7 and get that fianchettoed
Bishop I wouldn't say it's super
ambitious however in this position we're
also decided you know what g6 is not
aggressive enough for me g5 and it's
quite a move because it's like and the
game just got really double-edged very
quickly I thought that this was all
relatively normal I didn't like Queen b3
because I feel like black has to castle
anyway there's no counseling Queen side
and I don't don't like the Queen here so
this mu I didn't care for I thought why
would just play like maybe even h3 or
rook e1 I guess g4 maybe she was worried
about I would have thought about Bishop
e3 before 9bt too for this reason you
could also think about trying to open
the center but it probably blacks gonna
just Castle anyway so I just did not
care for Queen b3 but okay h3 and
honestly this game just got crazy the
Kings side blacks obviously trying to
play for f5 this structure change is
quite interesting because it seems like
these doubled pawns are bad
but honestly having these doubled puns
in front of your king when your
opponent's trying to attack is often a
really nice thing so and this is a
general rule I tell my students cuz
people get obsessed with double puns but
I'd say if pawns are doubled in front of
your King in a helpful way as in their
blocking your opponent's pieces they're
usually actually pretty good so but okay
this position I think is just nuts I
don't have any clear evaluation for you
here I thought my black might try h5
just to prevent white from playing g4
but okay c6 threatening d5 and then just
craziness I I don't have any other word
note how this pawn is immune to capture
for the moment because of takes t 6 and
this Bishop hangs so rook e8 Bishop b1
looks quite ugly but you have to keep in
mind that in some positions g4 d 4 all
of a sudden that Bishop gets unleashed
on the unsuspecting public so you have
to be a little careful he plays g4
probably did prevent that himself h4
kind of a fee structure if a knight this
pawn on g3 could be weak but also this
Knight has a clear path to improve
itself and the net and f1 tends to be
solid in this kind of structure but
honestly I just have no idea thoughts of
grabs a pawn comes back improves our
Bishop again this d4 move was a little
surprising to me it looks like his
structure is pretty good but maybe he
just got stuck he needed a way to
improve but now this Bishop on a2 looks
quite good to me so they trade rook e1
it looks like Tata has a pretty good
position she's up that pawn and it seems
like this attack is pretty well Connard
it looks like kind of a useless extra
pawn because here it's just doubled but
at the same time these pawns keep our
Kings safe and blacks King doesn't have
that luxury so if ever these pieces get
traded never know but okay rookie for
neither side wants to trade rooks
they're trying to be clever he wants her
to take on e5 and put the bishop on e5
hitting g3 she wants him to take on e4
and then pawn takes and then the d4 pawn
is weak
neither is obliging King h2 just
improving the King she trades now Queen
c4 threatening to come into g8 it's
starting to look pretty dangerous so
King h6 Bishop b4 threatening bishop
to look like black was on the attack but
as often happens when you push puns in
front of your King your own King can
come under fire 93
Bishop d2 so the question is whether
this Knight is stable if that Knight can
be taken it's gonna be probably all she
wrote for black Bishop f5 and in this
position I'm afraid to click the auto
update in case it hijacks my kit ever no
it didn't work last time also so so 93
she plays queen c1 that night looks like
a goner takes King will move back
somewhere either to g6 or h7 and again
looks like White's up a pawn and
honestly has the Sabre King it's not so
much that you're up upon its that when
your king is secure and your opponent's
is not it's so much easier to play so if
I wouldn't even say that extra pawn is
the major feature in the position it's
the King safety White's King is
completely safe blacks King is not so if
you're playing from White's point of
view you're actually playing for the
attack rather than anything else and in
the game King g6 was played Queen DD -
Bishop to f5 but there's another factor
ban which is that neither side has that
much time and as you know it's not like
they reach more floor if they get an
extra 30 minutes this is the drop of the
danger this time control they both are
playing on increment anything can happen
but honestly I like toss-ups chances
just because especially with low time
it's so hard to defend when your King is
the only one that's gonna get threatened
she's looking great against Grandmaster
4 on stuff and this would be a
spectacular win for her if she were to
do the she passed him in the leaderboard
right I think they're at the same
one-and-a-half yep that sounds right
it's for us of regretting g5 I don't
know if he's were getting g5 most likely
I mean I can just tell you from
experience that most grandmasters
especially when they played these ideas
they think at some point their positions
good always and I think that at some
point he probably did have a decent
position so I don't know if he regrets
that he maybe regret some later
decisions I would be regretting spending
lots of time but at the same time it's a
complex game and this is the danger of
shaking this many risks keep in mind
it's not over yet with both sides low on
time either one can blunder if the
Queen's trade quite honestly I don't see
white having anything
then this king works against you you
want your king active so if the Queens
trade there are definitely things gonna
happen I would say that it's very
unlikely Tata loses it but quite
honestly the game's not over yet and you
can't be totally sure but if she does
manage to pull him the point here it's
gonna be a pretty rough day and I'd say
ever on table will be pretty
disappointed I think she had made have a
good move with this Bishop d4 here looks
to me like quite a nice tribe with the
idea that if Queen takes d4 Queen g5
check takes here with check this H pawns
week and if King h6 Bishop f7 well that
then is not a fun day that's so Bishop
d4 I don't know maybe engines are gonna
tell me I'm a [ __ ] but Bishop D floor
looks like a pretty nasty move probably
he would have to drop back to to e7 but
now I mean anything can happen in fact
this did happen Bishop g4 Queen e7 and
now it's a question of do you take this
bishop but then maybe the trade helps
black a little bit although honestly
even after that trade it looks
unpleasant you could play Bishop c5
hitting the Queen again although this
one you don't actually hang the bishop
so it's a little trickier but in this
position rather than simply take the
bishop you can actually take this pawn
if you want or you can just play Bishop
e6 and you pin so you wouldn't this
Bishop again so this would actually be
kind of nice she ended up just taking on
g7 he takes with the King of course to
avoid Queen g5 check but quite honestly
still looks a little bit difficult to me
probably she should actually take her
time maybe put the pawns on b4 at a 5 to
fix these guys and then eventually go
after the Queen side using the fact that
the weak King means your Queen can't get
too adventurous so I don't know it looks
like and she indeed does play b4 which
isn't a decision I like she just wants
to put the pot fix the pumps on the dark
squares and really just blacks could
it's gonna suffer here as far as I can
tell and again with little time it's
just very difficult but I think this is
a decent practical decision she's not
trying to go for me she's actually just
trying to fix these pawns so it's very
where I get to other sentenced October
Brahimi
going for me but I think that she might
go for it later but she's trying to fix
everything so she has played b4 she has
played before and yep so maybe we can
keep an eye on this game for sure it
looks like a croc Chandra did go down to
jariabek hammer Akula so we should see
what happened there whoa yeah oh that
sounds interesting
let's take a look yeah I make lots of
sound effects
so yeah this opening was kind of a
strange one it was uh it was a scotch
and rather than play Bishop c5 Bishop b4
checker Knight f6 he plays Queen f6 I
know this is a system but it's a little
on the rarer side he plays Knight d5
which seems like the natural bra back
hitting this pawn Bishop c5 of course
taking this pawn would be ill-advised
because King d8 and if you grab the rook
that would not be a fun ending to the
game for white but of course he doesn't
play that he plays Queen e2 Knight c3
Bishop e3 so if you trade the Bishop c7
is just impossibly weak so he plays
Bishop a5 castles Queen side a 695 and
this was I thought a key moment I
thought he had to actually take this
Knight and it looks amazingly suicidal
but somehow there's no great discovered
check a bishop d4 check Queen e7 seems
to do it Bishop g5 Queen e5 if you take
now any Bishop check you have Queen e6
and nothing hangs so surprisingly this
might have been a possible option and
wait isn't gonna Bishop g5 check here oh
I'm sorry
you'd have to take with the people okay
yes mister g5 Chucky's Queen e6 and
doesn't seem to be anything here but
this is this is gutsy to have to play
this way and after 97 I thought that
blacks position was a little
uncomfortable the way I see it this
Bishop on b4 is almost like a stranded
sailor it's just kind of wandering
around aimlessly like it's not sure what
to do with this life and it's just very
difficult to play with a piece like this
it just doesn't have a happy home and
that means that it's hard for black to
just develop this Queen side oh and we
have a result here Josh Bartholomew I
believe
Eve yes he did win we'll get to that in
a moment I just want to show quickly how
this ended so yeah and honestly this
position just looked unpleasant this
Bishop on CA it's just sitting there
very sad and mopey and it's just very
unpleasant I don't know if if the game
finished queen d3 is a subtle threat
trying group take c7 mm and I don't know
if all this was accurate but Twite
honestly this looks unpleasant for for
black it's hard to defend when half your
pieces are not playing so this happens
looked like it got became quite a mess
to be honest with you but somehow that
King just does not look fun and sure
enough the night before runs into the
roof takes g7 check quite a move Queen
c3 a check f6 you have to block those
pieces you take this Knight and you
still have the attack despite being down
the exchange he doesn't even bother
taking the rook why would you trade
Queens and maybe this is could have been
saved by Akshay but quite honestly it
looks unpleasant and after this check if
King h7 roof g7 check you have to go
back and I'm sure there it's kind of
like dealer's choice here you can play
rook e7 you can play route g6 you can
try to mate somehow maybe there's just a
mate but quite honestly it looks just
massively unpleasant is this a windmill
situation right here
it absolutely is black and maybe try to
block with rook up 6 there's only things
so you might just want to take the Queen
but quite honestly anyone you know it's
it's better to just resign and not have
to see what your opponent does right ah
yes
so John Bartholomew did win as I said
these two connected pawns are just quite
strong yeah so once he allowed those
passed pawns it just was quite bad so
John decided to play very simply and
just trade off this bishop and play King
before I like playing simply when you
have such a beautiful advantage like the
connected passed pawns there's no reason
to complicate your life just win in the
most direct manner possible if you have
the opportunity so I like John's
approach again just trade the Knights
get everything so that those two pawns
win most people I think might just push
this pawn quite honestly that looks very
strong but he didn't want f3 and rook f4
check he didn't even want to make
calculate any of that he just wants to
keep his life simple 95 93 please trade
the Knights he finally does but quite
honestly these two pawns are just
even if somehow black wins this pawn
these two pawns the fact that they're
farther ahead means more than the total
pawn count so g5 rook c1 cutting off the
king and now the pawn just runs and he
just threw in the towel because
basically these pawns run and if the
King can't get anywhere near him it's
just dead lost so John Bartholomew
started out slow with half oh no one
wins his next two games he's now on +1 /
água who is leading gets not back to two
and a half out of four stuff Rula who
got her third win is now leading the
event so quite a mix up in the standings
in yeah the the top section is really
something else I'm taking a look at the
the live standings as they are yeah this
is a we have a lot of players at two and
a half and step relay at three yeah yep
nice for John yeah John yeah John John
is hard to dislike and I know cuz I've
tried no but I've known John a really
long time we grew up he's about my age
maybe a year old or so happy year older
but we played in the u.s. juniors we
played in the cadets I've known him a
really long time I don't know anyone who
has anything bad to say about him it's
just really nice guy he's a master of
promotion too he has his own you just
you know he was he's blogging or
vlogging about this event I should talk
to him and try to steal some of these
skills but yeah he's multi-talented guy
he's good at promotion really good
instructor like he's a really good
reputation as an instructor he's
lectured at some camps I've done he was
always one of the favorite lecturers but
he can also play some pretty good chess
as we're seeing the last couple rounds
yeah very solid player and you know but
if you make some mistakes he's gonna
punish you so that was so he's doing
quite a bit better Todd I've still going
at it that's the last game that's the
last game going on in that section there
are a few others we can look at it looks
like in this position Joel bonala is
going to beat Arron Korbin ski unless we
have an earthquake or a tornado or
something pretty strong you're in the
Midwest that is very true that's why I
say then I grew up on the East Coast I
wasn't used to the
tornadoes you're the hipster guy right
New Hampshire is where I'm from
originally yes living in Milwaukee now
but I'll always kind of be New Hampshire
its kind of always gonna be where I'm at
but yeah I mean this is basically just
over I expect that Aaron will resign
pretty soon there it is agreed they have
so that was that so I believe that means
that Joel moves up to three out of four
so doing pretty well for himself after a
tough loss I think in round one let's
see we have met Cinco the highest rated
by far as we know in the event looks
like he's turning the screws on Brendan
Jacobson who when you're zero out of
three and I've actually been in similar
situations having to defend against
really strong player becomes twice as
hard and between the two bishops and
being down upon I would say it's only a
matter of time before white reels in the
point but I should point out that
Jacobsen could have collapsed long ago
and that he's held on this long says a
lot to his fighting spirit and also just
that he's willing to defend a lot of
people they get bad tournaments they
have bad results they just throw in the
towel too easily and here he's still
fighting that's a good sign for him even
if he loses this game goes on for I
think that bodes well for the rest of
the tournament that he knows he can hold
on and at least for a while against such
a strong opponent in such an unpleasant
game I was up in the tournament hall and
looking at Brandon's emotions before the
rounds and they're always the same so
far you know at least and so it looks
like he's coming in each round in the
right state of mind and that's an
important thing um you know and again I
mean it's for anyone it affects them I
don't care how experienced or strong you
are when you start off that badly it
affects you so I feel like we should
point out another one of the games I was
gonna keep an eye on but because we've
had so many distractions of other games
being interesting I failed to do so was
a draw between Luis Carlos Torres roses
and tensile targets they agreed to a
draw here so it was actually very
shortly after we broke and we I was
asking you who you like you like black I
was kind of leaning towards white but
wasn't sure I try to say not sure in
case I say something silly
Queen f5 so he traded Queens which I
wasn't sure about I thought he might try
to use the Kings side but I guess it's
kind of locked up and after King g7
tantal offered a draw which was accepted
I would say after the Queen's trade the
H poem becomes last week I think blacks
should be the one playing on here and
I'm actually a little surprised that he
didn't I think that Tetzel maybe didn't
like his position earlier and sometimes
that affects your mindset later when you
think your position is you know when you
go from worse to equal and then you're
gonna be better sometimes people kind of
stop they're just relieved that they
didn't lose and it's not always the best
mindset a lot of the times you have to
really jump on those mistakes and say
wait am i better now if you're better
now you should be playing on and I think
that black has to be better here this
pawn is moving up to before the d6 pawn
is now a weakness more than a strength
remember how it was a thorn in black
side for a lot of the game I think it's
a weakness now so maybe it's just me but
I would say I would play on here if I
were if I were black but I'd imagine
that Lewis is actually very happy he got
away with the draw in this position and
he still is at three out of four very
nice score cancel is that 2 out of 4 I
believe so right still pretty solid
result considering he's one of the
lowest rated players in the event and I
believe he was a last minute addition so
both of these guys can't be too unhappy
yeah absolutely so let us move around
the grounds shall we
ah yep Joel did win as we pointed out
and the only game going oh my goodness
thought it was in an end game
so this happened they she played b4 this
was the last we saw so he plays Bishop
back to g6 solidifying the Kings side
the problem is when you have to be
distracted by the Kings side keep your
King safe do all this you can easily
forget about the Queen side and that's
very dangerous
King goes to h7 here Queen c4
threatening to sneak into g8 Queen e8 I
would remind you guys that both these
neither of these players have much time
so it's an easy position to make some
mistakes
a5 she locks down those palms taking my
suggestion
King g7 Queen d4 check King h8 Queen f6
quite honestly Ben this looks looks
really nasty to play even if objectively
you can draw somehow it just looks very
unpleasant the idea of Queen f6 is not
even to try to mate it's to play Bishop
e6 and go after these pawns black plays
Queen e4 and top two just plays Queen at
fates they're ending Bishop H
threatening Bishop g8 probably among
other things Queen e8 and she says you
know what I'm gonna trade these Queens
played this should be six and when
you're b7 pawn and this looks massively
unpleasant King goes to g7 the only
danger is because the white Kings out of
play sometimes that can ruin things but
I think these pawns are so weak thus a
pawn is so strong there's just not much
to be done
c5 was played she plays Bishop takes b7
and quite honestly it just looks lost
over yeah it's gonna be over it looks
that way because if you play first of
all if you move your bishop away you
just play if you move the bishop to b7
you just take the head shape it's over
if pawn takes pawn you play a6 a7 and at
the last minute you say hold the phone
you're not going anywhere and now you
either have to give up your pawn and
play Bishop c6 which should be easily
winning or you play Bishop c6 and now I
say you know what I'll let you have your
Queen
I'll Queen myself I'm up a piece with a
safe King you're toast
I think we should talk to Tata if
possible that would be pretty nice so
yeah in this position he played c4 she
played a six and he resigns here I'm
guessing that after c3 he didn't like
that she would simply get a queen and
then take this Bishop and that would be
that would be the end so toxic moves to
+1 were on so if I believed moves 2-1 so
obviously for her just really excellent
result in really excellent tournament
considering she started off losing the
first round and a tough one this was
quite a nice comeback and this is not
the first time that Todd Zeb has like
played up so to speak in a section that
does it
name makes sense so she's woman
grandmaster you would think she'd be
playing in the IM norm section but quite
regularly she's in the Grandmaster norm
section and art in our Gorman events and
she's always this is one of her best
performances I think starting off so
it's good to see her with because you
know she's been the GM and res here as
have you yeah so she asked even though
she's from Glendale California
st. Louis I'd like to think is her
second home it probably I mean she
spends a lot of time here she does she's
done commentary she's done she often
runs the Twitter but I would say it one
of the main reasons she also is in the
GM section is because she has all her
eye on norms so for her to play for I
have norms she doesn't need 8 a.m. norms
I think she already has four or five
right so but she almost always is out
raided by quite a bit but usually there
are obviously times she's had bad times
but I'd say more often than not she you
know plays up to the level of what she's
expected of her and really you know can
do some damage in these tournaments you
might lose a bunch of games but she'll
always get a few scalps alright and I
have just been informed that we are
gonna have time to barber home you know
on the show let's take a break when we
come back we will have Josh talking with
Tata and we hope that you're enjoying
this here this is the 2018 st. Louis
norm Congress from the st. Louis chess
club and u.s. chess champs calm if you
aren't checking out the games there be
sure you do because you can catch the
games live we only have one left
but tonight later at 5:00 p.m. we will
have the next round as well so when we
return we'll have Tata here from st.
Louis
[Music]
the question on Twitter from dem s I
should not have pronounced that that was
a bit of a champion
for those of you who are new to chess it
might look like VA 3 is an illegal move
here because white advances pawn to
square is not one but it still is
something we call on us all and you can
do that you have to do it instantly you
can't wait for a move like I'd say play
King Seven Kings you to because y'all
play four against Lawrence and now he's
going to play something against me which
we discussed at length during the course
of my steak yeah he told me this is that
g5 this was what I was kind of hoping
for because now I think we possibly know
who Lawrence this is not how she has
works certainly would be much much more
fun if chess actually work like this I
don't think it does however it does well
that's me regretting what I just said
how did I get from there to here is a
little bit beyond me and what's worse I
will never hear the end of it my quality
of life has just gone downhill
tremendously because I'm actually
sharing the office with the guy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi I'm Mike Matheny whether you play
chess for fun or want to boost your
child's academic performance come visit
the Chess Club and scholastic Center of
st. Louis right here in the chest
capital of the u.s. from a welcoming
diverse environment to a Scholastic
outreach program now in over 100 schools
our Center across from the world chess
Hall of Fame the Central West End has it
all so whether you've played for years
or never before we invite you to
experience all chess has to offer
there's a weekend vacation on one tank
trip in a nearby
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a moment comes in chess when you need to
test yourself at a different level chess
24 premium offers the tools that you
need to reach your maximum potential
from hundreds of interactive video
lessons to becoming part of the chess 24
community you can analyze with friends
or coach your students live you get
twenty four by seven coverage of chest
news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get it bashed
from the best and even challenge them to
a battle be the best chess player you
can be it's time to level up your game
with just 24 Premium Membership hello
everyone welcome back I'm here with
women's Grand Master tots of over ha
Myung congratulations on your win why
don't you happy I should play more
energetically in a signer but have you
seen age six before yeah I mean I knew
he was gonna play the 66 and I thought I
should get in before but I couldn't
quite manage like pretty good before
here especially before I thought yeah I
mean I think that's it shouldn't be
played just right away but yeah so yeah
the way I played so I played like normal
moves your first just cuz you don't
really ever care if he takes it and it
looked a little nicer but you know just
coz here like rookie ones that annoying
move so I wasn't sure but this all
looked pretty normal
yeah Quinn DD I wasn't I thought before
I put in my queendom between my
opponents then we're gonna be able to
develop this but let's give him some
problems but then the next few moves
castle of course and then h3 now I can
play what you want anymore
it's the knight age 5 yeah so here I
wasn't quite thrilled after Queen f6
because I cannot play Knight upon
three hangs ah so you gotta play tonight
eh - but this all looked it didn't look
that bad it just weird because I just
felt like at some point there might be
some kind of a sacrifice okay so where
do you think the turning point was 93 I
kind of liked because these doubled
pawns I don't really feel like you mind
I didn't get a bet that you would
playing out of four you had a four like
ninety four and maybe so you're trying
to play like 93 and put a night here
yeah yeah it looks like a reasonable
idea but after 97 it seems like it's
covered also so yeah but maybe at some
point I can play before or something
like if you have if the night ever moves
and I can play before but it looks like
just an unclear position it doesn't look
good yeah that's why I feel like my
opponent played g5 got a better position
they did on the phone yeah so it goes
it's amazing what you can get away with
sometimes but definitely there's queen
bee to bee move maybe yeah I realize but
then I didn't want to go back I thought
at least you know I have to you know
developes for a while so that that's
yeah but here I had no idea so here I
was actually also a really long time I
think that maybe like 20 minutes and
here's over an hour so 20 minutes on
move 70 months it's pretty good thing so
it takes days I thought you might even
just give up this vision never never
gonna happen is actually interesting at
that opening of the position benefits me
cuz I'm guess blacks King or because
just the king at some point I'm I played
before so you have to somehow develop
your pieces yeah you know maybe 244 what
surprised me I thought like here I
thought the black had to at least be
doing that again I wanted to go quints
it so I thought maybe now it's time to
forward only I don't make friends on v3
until the end then I thought okay six
Queen c7 if my Queen gets rapid right
you're going and strap leave it up to
the gods so 96
Bishop c5 should be one I liked
yes I guess yeah this should be one yeah
here I just honestly was
was going on I was an eider so I just
took the pawn yeah I mean jafari it kind
of threw me off yeah it's not before I
think night of three is coming like g4
night of three is coming and once I got
it but I think once ID and upon trade
often my position I thought it was gonna
be really good because both bishops
aiming at the king that makes sense yeah
I said I thought that d4 was really
dubious when he played that like mattify
I think maybe I should play Queen before
right away so there's the matter of five
or maybe here
aha so there's no one out of five
because maybe there's no that's fine we
can just trade is there is it possible
for black just to play age five and then
play your next move I mean it's just H
five it feels like blacks gonna probably
do that anyway at some point so I mean
and then I realize I'm up upon on the
king's head cuz I do extra fun yeah
but D four I definitely maybe he has to
do it but I just hated this move because
I felt like it gives you a breath of
life again which otherwise you wouldn't
get and even if he just kind of stays
here down the down the double pot I mean
Black has a nice Center I feel like
black always has at least some
compensation yeah before I thought your
position had to be very nice well sure
what my to be yeah so here I think my
most kind of K Metro which was very nice
because I didn't have a lot of time you
don't worry I think playing on increment
yeah if you don't have time natural
moves are your friends
so yeah you trade it off the rooks which
I thought was pretty illogical yeah
Rokon before either of you guys want to
take that was a little because I'm
constantly running into tactics I
thinking and I was like why did I do
this
like when I just think I mean it's
optically looks nice but I guess there
are tactical issues like with always 92
h4 and stuff like that or yeah I mean at
some point or maybe like I'm just
pinning myself I take the five right
yeah but it still looked like this
position looked very good for you yeah I
kind of disagree at age four I assume
just never worked because you're just
I'm I can just take the piece hmm can't
just check on take on see it oh yeah and
I also have Misha by fate yeah so but
yeah yeah here I thought that black had
to me just
sufficiently to Queen so I thought about
Queen before but I don't think that
anything is know that anything I'm
giving up the two bishops
yeah you give up the two bits III hangs
and the problem is in the endgame I was
talking about the Sun air that you might
regret your King in the middle game your
king is good in them here actually your
king is not so good after Quincy won he
would play I thought you might play King
h77 so the idea is there take one veto
they take on B - well so does black have
a particular it here you're just getting
out of the pen I'm just wondering like
if you could played before hmm
then you can take one to two and then
don't say we get the same position yeah
more or less I mean you don't have
Queenie to it but I mean I can also
trade and play Quinn upon but I'm not
sure if I wanna do that yeah yeah this
kind of feels like safer not as good as
the game for sure yeah but this
definitely look like a better tribe I
don't know
yeah very comfortable for you but again
he had no time also here I also thought
the efficiency for that doesn't quite
org was 54 here trying to me yeah not
quite the Queen yeah but Bishop before I
thought was very nice
Queen e7 yeah I was thinking it was like
Bishop c5 is actually yeah you can
probably just move back now like Queen
f6 or something no I think you can just
say goes I thought taking was bad
because you tried like there should be
six or something but yeah so yeah so you
took yeah I'm done here I cannot I want
to go we should be sick specialty but
then you have fish page six yeah but I
like you kind of kept a simple a
specially with little time and you just
kind of fix the pawns and again the way
I saw it was with these fixed pawns like
black has to still worry about the king
but a lot of the end games are also
dangerous and it's probably just too
much pressure
so one thing like I was thinking of
which pieces to try and I was like I
definitely shouldn't go to a king and
punish the King comes here lie
yes actually I've been like again I
don't have time so I'm just making notes
but I didn't know what my plan was going
to be so I thought at some point I could
have played b5 but I thought they fire
was better
yeah I thought you just yeah I
definitely you don't want to trade right
so I thought that well the thing is if I
play b5 I thought the bishop cannot live
the king so maybe I can just mean to be
someone policy so I wasn't sure so I
played a five and died night at me like
I was I didn't know if he just like
stays and doesn't like collapse it's
coming forward like what yeah like yeah
but let's say he doesn't like Queen for
me so Queen C it looks like something
Bad's gonna happen
yeah I guess you're just kind of you
know I have chicken bishop yeah I mean
this looks yeah again you cannot put it
on yeah yeah so I think that blacks just
gonna remove the Kings to week this
there's only probably about King game
six here King age six so this should be
one trade to King upon no okay um let's
see
so can you play I don't know Queen check
here Queen check here yeah I mean i
running out of time with it like I have
to win the position of somehow and I
wasn't exactly sure what to do I thought
maybe I can play going v6 a6 get the one
pawn and then get the other but the lady
here is you play a bunch of nothing
moves you gain time in the clock and
black has to find only moves with no
time I think they practically just zero
chances and sure enough he did allow you
to trade Queens I like the Bishop g8
check the game time nice touch and put
the kitchen AJ's and this looked quite
hopeless
I guess c5 and putting the bishop here
would be nothing Bishop f7 I think
everything takes there too so and here
you're too slow because I'm 55 you don't
take and this would probably be this
Ultima doing yeah this pawns weak but
okay less clear than what you did
you played Bishop takes b7 yeah and if
pon takes what we were looking at was
this I'm just gonna be up a piece Bishop
here I mean first I thought Bishop d6
and I thought I'm just gonna use this
mystic someone with you Stan but yeah
Bishop Bishop eb8 and Bishop c6 this
pawns too strong and if Bishop c6 you
just take it and now your king is
but after we should be 5u you could take
so instead see for a six yeah now again
I'm gonna be peace and that was it so a
nice game one two no you didn't win two
in a row but you've won two games here
at plus one
how does the rest of the Tony look for
you so far well I played masters that
left at least a fifty percent against
the grandmasters yeah so very nice
tournament I know you got a round at
five so I'll keep you here until then no
I think I'll probably let you go but any
last thought no I mean I'm still my next
round I actually have plugging this
paragraph it's and I played a good for
grandmasters from the first well he just
lost so maybe you can take advantage of
the situation like today on this
problems exactly well thanks for joining
us and best of luck in tonight's game
thank you all right join us when we come
back and we'll wrap up the show so
[Music]
[Music]
you could fly to Venice
[Music]
or Paris
or even Copenhagen
you could fly all over the world the why
when you could just come to st. Louis
your trip begins at explore st. Louis
calm a moment comes in chess when you
need to test yourself at a different
level chess 24 premium offers the tools
that you need to reach your maximum
potential from hundreds of interactive
video lessons to becoming part of the
chess 24 community you can analyze with
friends or coach your students live you
get twenty four by seven coverage of
chess news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get advice from
the best and even challenge them to a
battle be the best chess player you can
be it's time to level up your game with
just 24 Premium Membership be surprised
be intrigued be delighted the World
Chess Hall of Fame in st. Louis is
nothing you'd expect and everything you
love
three galleries highlight the history
culture and creativity behind the game
explore chess in ways you never imagined
it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together the world
chess Hall of Fame mind art experience
alright welcome back to st. Louis for
the 2018 st. Louis norm Congress we are
we are wrapping up around 4:00 but we
still have one round left to go later on
this evening at 5 p.m. central right
here in st. Louis and you can see it on
us chess champs calm I'm Ben Simon as
always with the wonderful Grandmaster
Josh Frieda and we have one section
that's completely wrapped up and I
believe only one game remaining yeah and
it looks like Mott Cinco is white is
going to be brand of Jacobson in this
game he's up a piece in a pond there's a
slight problem of the H pawn here if the
if somehow miraculously do you trade the
G the beat the G for pawn away and trade
the dark score Bishop's it is indeed a
draw but I don't think a player of
history like we do that most likely
he'll bring the king dat e6 box the King
out at some point maybe play g5 I think
it's just a matter of time until he
concludes this however he does have to
be slightly careful if he plays things
at the wrong moment he might not
he might be blow it but I don't think
it's very likely indeed and you can look
at the body language of these players
right here
you know there's despair and there's
just trying to figuring things out well
it's like look at Brandon it's like it
doesn't even care anymore what is he
doing right here you always care but I
think he's just kind of miserable but
again credit to him he'd held on a long
time in a very unpleasant endgame with
zero out of three that's not easy to do
so it's gonna be unfortunate for him if
he's 0 out of 4 but again you know
there's always a chance to come back but
in round robins it's tough because
there's pairings
I guess they get easier than what Cinco
but they don't get that much easier
right now once again Mexico is the
highest rated player in both fields yeah
so not an easy pairing is black when
you're ohon 3
but why don't we check out the standings
in the GM section right yeah all games
are finished and here here's where we
stand after four rounds yep we got so
lucky do in clear first with three out
of four after bouncing back from her
loss last night at two-and-a-half we
have a very very large group tied for
second between grandmaster mark parag wa
AIIMS camera cool of patel and
bartholomew as well as wgm tata abraham
yen so quite a lot of people chasing
Gurevich in back with half a point but
again you know between him and chandra
always look for people to catch back up
but it looks like so far
still plenty plenty of life ahead in
this for me and I'd like to see the
pairings for the Grand Master norm
section because you know we're just
about halfway through yeah and things
are really starting to matter the hell
if you do the math so here's what we're
gonna see it tonight at 5:00 p.m.
yes so definitely look for Chandra so
lucky you by reading Chandra is the
favorite there so but so low-key who's
leading the tournament Chandra is having
a rough one he'll really want to win
this game not just to bounce back but
beating the leader is always a nice
feeling other games to look out for
gravis trying to score his first point
as white against Hinrich cool of it'll
be a tough task talked about brahim Yin
is playing black against the previous
leader mark Parag wa Paraguay is white
will want to bounce back from his loss
but he just lost the tough game so
sometimes that'll make things a little
difficult but a lot of interesting
pairings and I look forward to seeing
that round now how many of the
grandmasters tots have played so far
she's played three of the grandmasters
so far so two and a half out of four not
a bad score right and so that that will
be the final one right there that will
be the final one and then it's easy
sailing only really strong I am the rest
of the tournament so easy yeah and then
Stubb reuleaux who's playing like a
monster in the last round so piece of
cake right so let's see we have three
minutes for event Cinco and yeah this is
actually a little tricky let me just
show you like one of the things that can
go wrong I'm gonna hijack this position
and play a couple silly moves so bear
with it
say something like this happens right
and you trade these if I put my King
here you might actually struggle to win
because this Bishop moves back and forth
and you can never trade dark score
bishops you can put the pawn on h6
Bishop when I fade and bring the King up
here but I'm always gonna play King g8
at some point I don't actually have to
play King h8 this was just an
illustration probably leave the King
here again I think these positions are
all one but you have to be a little
cautious one little slip and sometimes
you can blow it and then you feel like
an idiot so it's important to always
keep your guard up but I think he will
find the way to win this position by
outmaneuvering the black king but again
you still have to be careful but I'm
pretty sure we're gonna see a white win
here why don't we check out the rest of
these standings for the IM group just so
we can catch you guys up yeah I don't
know if we have those prepared Oh
perhaps we do what do you do so this is
assuming Matt Sango wins his game yes he
does not then Jacobsen will have scored
his first half point but most likely
these will be the standing so you see
Matt Senko heavy raiding favorite but
still tied for the lead with three out
of four with banal and Torres but
definitely the I am showing their class
thus far I would say it's funny cuz
Motte sango's probably still losing
rating with 300-foot he's definitely
kind of back on track and then Josh
colas won so he's kind of back in the
plus column everyone else fighting at
50% or below Josh have you played in a
tournament situation one of these Norma
vents as a grandmaster I have and Sonia
time how do you feel about the prospect
of nothing to gain and everything to
what are you talking about I get to
prevent people from because I live for
this it's it's a pleasant thing I
actually played a tournament in Canada I
didn't get invited back because I
stopped everyone from becoming home yeah
that's bad PR yes yes I didn't get
invited back so you have to then another
tournament though actually here at the
club is after us championship I was I
had a great US Championship I was a
little bit exhausted playing a bunch of
strong kids kids like seve on before he
became a GM all these people it did not
go well
I should get invited back because of
that result but we'll see it's always
good though to really try to be like you
know what you're not going to be coming
today right so there is motivation but
definitely not as motivated probably as
the people trying to get their titles
well right and you know you do have some
reading points to lose there you know
things don't go your way so I always
have rating points Tallulah yeah right
okay well how close do you think we are
to seeing a finish here I would say it
really depends because it's one of those
things it depends on the time it depends
on how much the defense goes aha
we did see a development though in this
position this is actually quite
interesting if we can pull it up quickly
yeah so here he actually found a way to
trade and this is a very strange-looking
trade he got his King in again probably
this was not strictly necessary but in
this position he's up a piece he decides
to sacrifice a piece for upon the idea
of course after you take the bishop
probably he'll play king g6 first to
keep this King boxed out take this pawn
and it's a win and you have to be a
little bit careful because if you
obviously if you allow the bishop to
sack for the Jeep on oh no what am I
talking about it's not even the right
Bishop it's the dark square bishop this
is just over so bishop goes back you
take you move put the pawn on h7 Bishop
f6 just game over here pretty easily
something like this will happen bishop
to have six my guess would be he might
even resign if it were a LightSquared
Bishop it's still a win if you both have
LightSquared Bishop but it would at
least be you have to show some technique
here just very easy win
so Bishop G a check is actually a really
nice way to go about it sometimes it's
easier to win up to pawns and we're not
put on on a piece right surprisingly so
yeah I expect that I think Oh a win and
then it's gonna be pretty much over I
don't have any moves but my guess will
be it's gonna be very fast right and we
I've been informant we have the pairings
for the next round for the International
Master norm section let's take a glance
at those yeah so we have men Jacobsen
cannot catch a break he plays Luis
Torres the second one of the other top
players in this event as white in the
next round
again we'll he'll be definitely looking
to score his first points I'm sure even
if he gets a draw
he'll be at least a little bit relieved
it's always a good feeling to get on the
board and probably Luis Torres knowing
his opponent situation will really try
to press to get the clear lead and once
again it's all play all this is
round-robin so you don't get to avoid
anyone and so you get to play the people
you want to play but the people you
don't want to play you got to play them
too so I'd say Benoa against Mott Cinco
is also an interesting pairing I believe
joel is also in the lead so playing max
anko could be a good pairing we'll see
how that game goes but again all the
games have quite a bit of potential now
we didn't really talk about it too much
while waiting for this game to end here
oh we might be I don't think we're gonna
have to wait - right yeah I was afraid
before we might have to but yeah he did
play king g6 and yeah he's just gonna
win that pawn and it's gonna be pretty
much over guys this is not still me
black as a bishop I think yeah I just
like to point out an important thing
Bishop takes age six yeah I mean it's
gonna be pretty much over very soon I
guess he's still playing a played Bishop
d4 Bishop to g5 Bishop f6 new designs
okay he doesn't even play the show six
just but yeah mister f6 h6 is coming
it's gonna be pretty much over
so yeah Jacobsen at zero out of four
pretty rough events but again still
plenty of time and not Cinco moves to
three out of four so he's at least
catching up to his expected score but
we'll see he's definitely not in the
clear via so well we've already shown
you the standings and like the savants
that we are we predicted correctly so
that will do it for tonight remember
five PM us chests champs calm you will
see the next round of play and then
tomorrow 11 a.m. and 5 p.m. as well the
penultimate round on Monday the final
round on Tuesday and Josh and I will be
here every day at 2:00 p.m. for you so
this show was produced by the world
greatest production be team Dennis LaRue
is the technical advisor Isaac's rants
is audio and graphics our technical
director is Danny Machuca for Grand
Master Josh Reed L my name is Ben Simon
we'll see you tomorrow
and until then so long from the Show Me
State
[Music]
you